[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys
and welcome back to the leia hile pen
show
as always this is powered by icon plus
so i'm going to give you guys a really
quick
news announcement um so south korea's
pohang city embraces digital
transformation
by building its very own data economy on
icon loops is my id
korea's first and only blockchain based
digital id service so as always
some really cool news coming from the
icon network i also want to say a really
quick thank you
um to my sponsors block 5 so i actually
use them to earn 8.6
interest on my usdc if this interests
you then i'm gonna put the link um
in the comment section in the
description and i think it's in the
tweets so
you can actually grab 25 if you click
the link and sign up and deposit and get
some interest with them so that's really
cool
so really interesting today bitcoin is
looking like it might reach eleven
thousand dollars
we don't know what's happening so of
course i've got a very cool trailer
joining me today it is
crypto mecca crypto michael how you
doing
i'm doing great how are you yeah i'm
good i'm good it's really cool to have
you today because
i think you know it's been quite a hell
of a month we've seen bitcoin sort of
moving
sideways everything's looking pretty
quiet i don't we'll talk about defying
what that's doing later but it looks
like bitcoin might touch eleven thousand
dollars today what do you think
well yeah actually uh we have seen the
triangle which is a technical structure
but uh the bullish news
surrounding square acquiring a 5k
btc for 50 million is pushing the price
up and it's uh
even long term a very bullish bullish
signal for the market so we might
actually crack 11k
it's the heaviest hurdle to take and if
11 breaks then we might get new highs
and that's uh a great signal yeah i
think it's absolutely brilliant i mean
we hear
more and more major players getting into
bitcoin so i think something like this
is
obviously sort of what i guess sort of
you know created this mini
run or sort of woken woken up the beast
but everything's going on
but i kind of want to focus today on
crypto and bitcoin in general because we
always talk about
bitcoin you know buy bitcoin bitcoin is
the next revolution we always talk about
you know the banksters
but i think it's so important to
understand what the actual problem is
with the traditional financial system
and i kind of just want to go back to
basics in understanding that
so in terms of hyperinflation inflation
just from a really simple standpoint to
start off with what would you say is the
biggest issue
with the traditional financial system
and why are we looking to build
something completely new
um i think the whole issue is that in
the basics it's an
inflationary and debt build system so
everything is surrounded by
um trying to achieve two percent
inflation every year which is
um only fueling uh the rich and the poor
remain poor which is also what you see
in the recent data that's been coming
out
the gap between rich and poor is only
increasing
um so it's all starting by the
fundamentals that they
they want to achieve two percent
inflation which is
essentially not even needed if you want
to uh
uh get a great system going and because
of that
um you actually get that within combined
with the low rates that you can have
a ton of debt without any issues because
it will just be
worth less over time because of the
inflation so it's risk-free to actually
have a lot of debt
which is faulty in general but when we
sort of say you know
bitcoin is this hedge against
hyperinflation
when i tell people this they often think
it sort of sounds like the most
ridiculous thing they've ever heard just
because we're not seeing inflation rates
like you're seeing in countries like
venezuela for example so
is it that much of a big deal or are we
sort of
doing this for the sake of you know
looking at the broader picture over 100
years and sort of saying you know
especially what we've seen at the moment
you know all this printing or more money
will only affect
our currency only devalue our fiat
currency over hundreds of years
well like um we've got the issue with
hyperinflation in countries like
venezuela
and turkey and lebanon and argentina for
instance and that's a different topic
than the us dollar
i've seen people saying that the us
dollar might go in hyperinflation or
inflation in general
and i think that that's the if the
dollar goes in hyperinflation that's
probably the last
currency to do that as it's the world
reserve currency
so that other currencies are dropping
down and are going in hyperinflation is
actually that they are flying towards
the us dollar
so in these countries the demand for
bitcoin or other safe havens
is actually increasing and that's what
you see with a really big
community in turkey a big community in
south america because of it
as there is demand with the us dollar
it's different
as that's most likely not going in
hyperinflation it seems very odd to be
the world reserve currency going into
hyperinflation
but in case of deflationary systems or
deflation bitcoin can actually also be
in hatch
and that's what you have to go back
about about 100 years
to the big crisis in the 1930s we've
seen germany going in
hyperinflation because of the war and
all the debt they had
but the us dollar went into deflation
and that deflation
surrounded a lot of social unrest and
because of the social unrest gold
rallied with 600 percent
in those 10 years during deflation
so it's not depending on inflation
hyperinflation on deflation it's just
any of these will affect the price of
bitcoin and other safe haven
and i also just want to get your take
because you know when we talk about
um and when we talk about hyperinflation
and we sort of say okay that's not sort
of what we're
seeing you know in countries like
america for example
we're not sort of seeing hyperinflation
but ultimately
you know there is inflation so
you know you you know it doesn't really
make sense to leave your money
sitting in a bank because you know look
at it 10 years later
um and it loses its value so is it
is it so much is it more than just sort
of looking at inflation is it more just
looking at
bitcoin as a sort of separate entity
which is
you know a deflationary asset that you
know we appreciate the technology behind
it and we're sort of just looking at it
as
an alternative just like we look at gold
and silver so it's sort of
a parallel option i think it's uh a
better option than gold and silver to be
honest as
it's quite hard to carry gold around
that's just one of the basic arguments
and bitcoin in itself is is
indeed like the best 30 years we've seen
that equities and real estate have been
great options to put your money in but
we might be going towards the end of
this
cycle as the economies always go in
cycles and we've had a crisis in 2008
and the
governments did not decide to make the
right decisions they actually made the
wrong decisions causing a bigger crisis
to go ahead
from here so
in the past 30 40 years it has been a
great decision to go into real estate
and to go into equity markets however
these become overvalued at this point
if you look at companies like amazon and
every time when i say something about
amazon there's always those uh
moxies coming around saying that i'm
just berries and
attacking them but the variation is just
too high for these companies so at some
point the big guns
will start to sell their positions in
amazon just to hatch themselves or just
to go to a different asset class to
true uncertainty so that's the different
part of a cycle and
right now the valuation of gold and
silver is just low and bitcoin is a
better option
than gold and silver so okay
so essentially the same okay
so you say it's a better option i think
that's super interesting so
i have to ask you that and in terms of
you know gold guys like
peter schiff why can't he get on board
with bitcoin or even somebody like
warren buffett like why can't these
people
get on board with bitcoin i mean do you
think they secretly are on board with it
um they might
there's also the consensus that
uh for instance some people uh over here
at the
amsterdam stock exchange there's the tv
show which is at josette which is a
dutch
national tv show and they had to be
bearish on bitcoin
while the people saying it were actually
in bitcoin themselves
oh i hate that i hate that so much
that's yeah
i mean that's just national tv and what
they want to express
the same goes for big investment funds
they had to be bearish on gold and
silver and were not allowed to have gold
in their funds but privately they
actually had gold and now they are
coming out with saying you should
decrease your position in u.s dollars
you should increase
your positions in gold and silver so
saying a is mostly not what they
actually have or what they actually mean
um if you are understanding gold you
probably also understand bitcoin i i
can't understand if you could be bullish
on gold embarrassing bitcoin as it's
essentially just very identical asset
classes
that's so interesting um you know i
think we will sort of i mean we've
already seen people
do um you know 180 u-turns on bitcoin so
perhaps we'll see
you know these guys sort of do the same
thing um but all along they were
perhaps bullish i don't know but i want
to talk about the term banksters because
as comical as that term is
where did it come from right so why do
people think
you know the bankers are gangsters
basically what are they doing
um with our money well
all tons of stuff that we don't know and
they're doing
like every day you can see new
laundering stuff
or new tricks they have made or new
assets they have made
or they're just building financial
instruments to make a lot of money with
our money actually i'm taking a ton of
risks
with our hard working money
just for their own for the sake of their
own and
that's your issue with our our system i
assume
i mean initially the bank was a place
where you were storing your money
and that money that's been stored there
was used to get a mortgage loan for
other people
so that's the initial id of a bank and
right now
uh the average liquidity inside the bank
is two or three percent
98 is being used to make money
out of risky uh instruments which is
we don't need it but that's how our
system is built and that's why it's
fragile
you say fragile but you know when i talk
about this with people
outside of our crazy crypto world they
don't fully get it they sort of think
i'm being you know this wearing the
silver was it the tin foil hat and being
a conspiracy theorist and
i've even had people that i used to work
with because i used to do more
traditional media and
like solely actual you know news
terrorist attacks migrant crisis trades
and all that stuff and
they think i'm being they think i'm
talking about conspiracies when i talk
about
you know what the banks are up to and so
on and so on so why is this so
difficult for people to grasp people
that aren't in the space
why is it so hard what do you think is
wrong
the people you were talking to and then
probably it's also the generation of my
parents
they have lived on this planet with 50
years of trust in the government
and the current system that they are
living in so if you are
saying that the system they are living
in is faulty and wrong
it's it's very confusing for them
because they don't understand okay
and then then what do i have to believe
what is actually trustworthy why
why are you saying this so it's for them
very hard to get out of that cage
because they have been experiencing the
previous 50 years
or 40 years and they believe in that
system
and i do believe that during the corona
crisis and corona pandemic
more ice have been opened of people that
um
well governments in general are not
trustworthy as they seem to be
so yeah i mean yeah absolutely and i i
think i was out for dinner with a friend
last night and i was sort of trying to
explain to her
um you know why i'm doing what i'm doing
why i love what i'm doing and for me it
just sort of became like the perfect
example to sort of say well hang on the
last few months governments have just
been or central banks have been printing
you know pumping trillions and trillions
of dollars into the economy
and for me that was just such a
fantastic example and for her
it was so real and relevant so you know
she was able to fully
grasp that concept so i definitely think
everything that's going on is
is incredibly bullish for bitcoin uh it
actually is i mean
the whole fun point is is that that
people in general are reactive and no
pro
not proactive and if you take the
example of my country
and the whole crisis surrounding
positive corona tests and everything
around that in march we've had an
explosion of coronavirus tests
and they had to react based on that
and they have said okay we've had that
we have had a lockdown for months we
don't want to have that again so the
next time we're going to act earlier
and now we're six months further and the
exact same problem
is happening again the tests and
positive tests are exploding and we all
get new meshes
and they have been too late again
just because people make the exact same
mistakes again and don't dare to make
proactive decisions
and that's the exact same thing with the
financial system
if the big leaders have made proactive
decisions in 2008
we would not have the potential crisis
that we are facing
but they did not do that because of the
sake of their own
career or whatever there is yeah i think
i think there's a lot of sense there and
i think
that's just the natural nature of humans
i think even
the whole idea is slightly different but
even the whole idea of humans sort of
like
you know buying high and selling low
it's that sort of
reactive behavior and even though you
know
i mean look like i'm long-term bullish
on bitcoin i think
this is my predictions to know and quote
me but i have a sense
of whatever that i think bitcoin will be
around 18 000
at the end of 2020 right it's just a
prediction off the top of my head
and even though i know in my head you
know even though i'm thinking okay
that's where it's going to be
it's still hard to keep you know
stacking stats and
because at the end of the day there's
still risks so
when bitcoin goes up we then buy so
that's kind of like our reactive
nature but i want to ask you about um
the dollar's lifespan because that's
something that i speak to a lot of
people about and a lot of people have
said you know
it's got x amount of years and that's
coming to an end soon
do you have any thoughts on that at all
and is there a lifespan to the dollar at
all um people are saying that
the dollar is going away or the life
spent spending of the dollar a day
that's basically saying the same as that
there's a different planet
around here with life that's actually
oh okay i mean it's just it's
as um in the past 100 years we've had
the u.s dollar
yeah not reserve currency before that
we've had the british pound
and the british pound lost the uh
position as being a world reserve
currency because the us dollar came
around and they just did not have the
funds anymore
but the british pound is still around
but it's not that position
yet anymore
defining a world reserve currency or the
monetary place they have is just
based on how economies evolve and right
now uds
is the first one but they have also the
biggest problems they are
the fbi center of our system and just
also the issues there but is it going
away never
okay so you okay so you think
that what's more likely is that we could
see what happened to
um the british pound so something else
could maybe even a crypto maybe bitcoin
could become
the world reserve currency and the
dollar could be second to that
um yeah that's good um it could also be
that we're going into a transition
phase of the us dollar losing their its
position
and um gold and bitcoin will do well in
the coming 10 years and then
maybe the chinese currency will take
over or something
it's very hard to imagine that bitcoin
will be the world's reserve currency i
don't see that happening
yet that's just it's just too early but
it is
an asset class to save yourself in case
of a devaluation of the dollar
that's the basic so it's a safe haven
will be a world reserve currency at some
point it's technology
i don't know it's one of the best right
now can it be
uh taken over by a different currency at
some point it could
we don't know but for the next 10 to 20
to 30 years it's one of the best options
you have
and holding us dollars is also a risk so
holding whatever is a risk it's true
it's true
um speaking of risk i do want to chat to
you about d5 because
you um post a lot about d5 you look at a
lot of different charts
um you've been posting a lot about wi-fi
so talk to me about yearn finance
what is going on i mean august was quite
the month for it it sort of came out of
nowhere and then it you know
what was it around 32 000 did it go
higher i can't remember but
tell me about it what is going on um
defy has seen a very large momentum in
the summer
and that was just similar to the ico
mania we've seen in 2017 i just
you could create a simple token on uni
swap and just make
a lot of money out of it and now it's
coming back to reality
so the scam projects will go to zero and
the good projects will cons
will just exist still uh with
uh urine finance particularly i don't
know it's just having a sell-off
just like any other d5 project and
right now we're going to see the
bottoming of it or hopefully the
modeling of it and then the real project
was just
start kicking off just like chain link
did it's a great project and it started
to kick off
after the long accumulation range it's
just back to reality
the only issue is is that those cycles
become shorter
it's two months and that goes down
ninety percent
so but you think like the fundamentals
are there with the project you're
sort of electron d5 but literally on
finance
i'm bullish on d5 as it's it's
if you think about it it can be
something really big um
about projects particularly it's quite
hard as there are so many
um i've not been i've just been trading
it as a chart
i've been going into projects like
balancer or curve
and uni swap as well these are some
decent projects and during finance i
still have to look into it but as
i've been receiving lots of projects
that are into dfi
looking for seat investors and private
rounds and stuff and i'm like okay this
is such a big signal that we are back
into the ico mania
but you say mania then so do you think
this is just like a d5 bubble
or is there more to it i mean we'll get
i do kind of want to just like briefly
touch on nfts but we'll do that at the
end so like we'll get to that but
you know there always seems to be a
craze a hype
and i think it's undoubtable that you
know that's been deep by over the summer
so
is it just like an ico boom or is there
more to it
um if you would ask me during the summer
if there is a bubble yeah
i would have answered yes and now the
bubble else has popped already
just going back to reality i think the
majority of the dfi investors are into
depression right now
and now we're seeing a phase where we
can start building so it's just the same
indeed as the ico mania in 2017 only
faster
so we see another hype cycle like we've
seen with d5 in the previous months
probably we will uh but that will
probably be
like 2021 when there's some really
fundamental
upgrades being made yeah and you talk
about upgrades and like i've been
speaking to a couple of different
um i guess like decentralized exchanges
um and a lot of the time i hear them
sort of sell themselves
to me and sell sell them something their
product and they often say that
we're like uni swap but we're better
because we have a better user experience
okay
so i kind of want to get your thoughts
on user experience and how
likely it is for this stuff to actually
go mainstream right because
it's supposed to be the new way you know
taking loans um you know lending and
borrowing and all this stuff
supposed to be better than doing it and
the traditional way through a bank
so it's difficult for the average person
to do this so
how the hell are we going to get to a
point where deep i actually becomes
you know this normal thing that normal
people can do
i think we get to that stage with
blockchain in general when people don't
know that they are using blockchain or
using a decentralized exchange so
these people would not understand how it
works or how
it's it's built up it's the same as
internet my parents are using internet
but they have no clue how it's built up
they're just using it
and i think defy is one cycle behind
bitcoin ethereum
um and i'm not that bullish on
decentralized exchanges in the short
term
as i do believe that the money will come
from institutional investors and
institutional investors will not have
the ability to invest
in uni swap or sushi swap or whatever
there is they are going to invest into
bitcoin and ethereum
as that's the two main propositions for
them
and the other coins are just too risky
so i think the old bull market the big
cycle for the next year is going to be
fueled by people stepping into bitcoin
ethereum
and actually having ethereum is exposing
yourself
to divide risks already as everything is
built on ethereum
yeah no i i hear you and i i think you
you mentioned you know
more people getting into bitcoin and um
i'm sure everybody watching already
knows but it's super interesting to hear
that jack's company square actually um
invested 50
million dollars uh into bitcoin so what
are your thoughts on that you know like
why
do you think he did this and do you
think it's kind of
following on from more people getting
involved you know we had about like
michael saylor
and so on and so on but i know that we
all know that jack is already bullish on
bitcoin you know it's the only thing
he's got in his twitter bio um but what
do you think that's gonna do for the
price and also
do you think more people are gonna
follow after this i think they will
um i'm as you can see i'm seated here at
the amsterdam stock exchange and there's
a front in the back
and you can't see it but above there
there's the first
otc desk in the netherlands that
actually got a license from the dutch
bank
what we see from there is that a lot of
these big
funds and private banks as well are
interested in investing in bitcoin or
having exposure towards bitcoin
so it's already happening in the back
and retail investors
don't see that because it's just a
different market
so those people already know
the potential of bitcoin and they want
to have exposure
retail investments investors will not
make the market they will not move the
market it's those big guys that will do
that
yeah so yeah that's they are going to
push the markets and it's something
we're seeing already
it's already going on for a year or so
that they're accumulating positions
and they will only push the price
further up at some point
okay so look you know you are a trader
um i gotta get your predictions
so i spoke to nicholas merton he told me
i think he said
we'll sort of like crack that 20k um
that 20k barrier by the first quarter of
2021 and then he spoke about crazy highs
i think between 100k to 200k by 2023. so
give us your thoughts
um it is high it's really high it is
i think we're going to crack the
all-time high indeed next year it's
quite hard to do that in this year but
there's still the
vulnerable case of an implosion of the
economy in the u.s so if that's going to
happen
it might be that we're dropping down as
well just because of the rush towards
liquidity
um that's what you saw in 2000 2008 with
gold as well they
it dropped 30 40 so then we get an
extended bear market or accumulation
range but indeed
if the bottoming is there
not too long i know um i think we we
could see some heavy movements as well
so i think we're going to crack
the autumn high somewhere uh
end of quarter one 20 21 i do agree on
that where we are at 2023 i don't know
i i don't know i'm gonna say 100k is
that's just
at some point we will but how will be
how will the world economy be in that
period
yeah but from you from your perspective
you know people talk about bitcoin being
this non-correlated asset so
to what extent is it correlated because
i think it would be incorrect to say
that it's not correlated
because we've sort of seen you know that
it sort of is especially
the crash well i say crash but what we
saw back in march with it you know
dropped to 4k
um how correlated is that
uh correlation topic is just on and off
like if you're going to zoom in
regarding correlations then
probably the past week it has been
moving alongside
equities in the week beforehand it's
with gold
if you look at the bigger picture i
think everything is correlated towards
the us dollar
and when the us dollar is showing
weakness which we have seen in 2017
uh bitcoin will search um
similarly with 2014 and 2015 2016 the
dollar strengthened 2080 tonight's 19 as
well and bitcoin showed weakness
so the moment that the dollar is going
to show weakness
um i think bitcoin will search heavily
and the gold and silver as well
i'm just similar with 2000 2006 gold did
a tremendous job
while the dollar was weak some very
exciting times right so we're
approaching half an hour i want to just
get your final
thoughts on the market whatever you want
to say i'm going to make you full screen
and you can you can you can stay your
bet
say your bet go on say your bet oh
man honestly i don't know what americans
are going to bring you so you put me on
a position here
um i think if you want to invest long
term in bitcoin just accumulate a little
bit every month that's the best decision
you can have
don't push yourself towards leverage
trading platforms as people are saying
that you should
or that you see it on twitter that
people are doing that
just accumulate a little bit every month
stack it up
live your life um and don't stare at the
markets all day
and don't stare at the markets it will
put your emotions down
there you go i want to thank you so much
it's such a pleasure having you on the
show i want to thank everybody
um for watching thanks to icon plus
and of course thanks to blockbuy um and
thank you so much for coming on
thank you for having me have a great day
alright we'll see you all
next week bye bye